herzlich willkommen in meiner torten ich
hab heute ein richtig leckeres rezept
für euch ich werde nämlich etwa tiramisu
machen
ein tiramisu habe ich euch ja schon mal
gezeigt aber dass hier etwas ganz
anderes das ich nämlich ein erdbeer
tiramisu hier könnt ihr das auch sehen
und natürlich schmeckt dieses etwa
tiramisu auch mit anderen obstsorten
aber erdbeeren sind natürlich die
favoriten
ich habe mich dazu entschlossen bei
diesem thema mich so auf ihn zu
verzichten weil beim einem klassischen
tiramisu habe ich auch hohe mit dabei
aber hier habe ich das nicht weil ich
einfach finde das ist unerfreulich so
passt deswegen lockere ich die creme
dieser mascarpone creme mit etwas quark
und sahne auf und zeigt euch das jetzt
einfach gleich in der küche getalkt wird
das ganze hier mit etwas minze wie ihr
sehen könnt und auch zitrone und orange
sind in diesem rezept vorhanden und
machen das ganze richtig sommerlich und
fresh dieses rezept ist in nur zehn
minuten hergestellt maximal 15 einfach
durchs kleine schnippeln der erdbeeren
deswegen nehme ich euch jetzt direkt mit
in die küche und starte ich habe hier
die zutaten und zwar wenn ich heute eine
ziemlich große form benutzen und in
dieser form habe ich das noch nicht
gemacht und deswegen habe ich jetzt
einfach mal die doppelte menge von
meinem normalen rezept genommen
die form fast zweieinhalb liter wasser
also das habe ich vorher noch aus
gemessen
das könnt ihr dann so als orientierung
nehmen das erdbeer tiramisu habe ich
jetzt hier mal der zutaten und beim
abbau tiramisu oder so da gibt es
wirklich tausend variationen tausend
varianten
ich habe jetzt nicht heute für diese
variante entschieden auch mit kaffee
aber ich werde auch mal noch in therapie
so im glas machen ein erdbeer tiramisu
und da werde ich das ganze etwas anders
gestalten
und jetzt zeigt sich einfach mal die
zutaten also auf den ersten blick nicht
erschrecken es ist ziemlich viel aber
ich möchte ich einfach jetzt auf einen
schlag alles zeigen
ich habe ich löffelbiskuits die werde
ich heute aber nicht benutzen ihr könnt
als grundlage entweder löffelbiskuits
benutzen oder amaretto ich habe mich
heute für die amerikaner entschieden
weil die einfach viel aromatischer
schmecken dann habe ich hier etwas
kaffee also das ist jetzt eine
espresso ist es also ein ganz starker
kaffee das sind etwa 150 milliliter hier
habe ich noch 150 milliliter orangensaft
oben einfach diesen kaffee ein bisschen
auszugleichen
und dieses tiramisu ein bisschen
frischer zu machen also dass hier sind
die zutaten für die basis und jetzt die
zutaten für die creme
hier habe ich einmal den saft einer
zitrone ein kilo mascarpone 400
milliliter sahne
hier habe ich 300 gramm sahne quark
könnte aber auch gerne magerquark nehmen
150 gramm zucker
denn das kakaopulver brauchen wir später
zum topping und hier habe ich natürlich
erdbeeren
das sind jetzt unsere eigenen erdbeeren
aus unserem eigenen garten
ihr könnt natürlich aber auch eltern
kaufen aber achtet darauf dass ihr da
deutsche erdbeeren benutzt weil es
einfach
die schmecken einfach besser und
natürlich ist es dann ökologisch etwas
wertvoller
die haben wir genug geld hat mir
geholfen
ich hab jetzt etwa ein kilo erdbeeren
genommen da können sich aber auch mehr
oder weniger benutzen und es dürfen auch
ruhig die erdbeeren sollen die ein
bisschen verrutscht sind und die werden
wir später daran schneiden bei erdbeeren
ist es immer ganz wichtig dass ihr die
erst dann wenn ihr sie auch verwendet
weil sie ansonsten ziemlich schnell zu
matschen und die überleben dass man
wirklich keinen tag und gehen euch dann
kaputt und ich benutze dann noch etwas
frische minze weil die nämlich ganz
perfekt zu diesem gericht passt richtig
lecker zu den erdbeeren passt und ich
würde sagen ich nehme die zutaten und
startet gleich bevor sanierer mehr die
ganzen kekse weg ist
zuerst wird es die sahne steif
geschlagen und danach stelle ich sie
einfach kurz zur seite und ihr müsst
euch da auch keine gedanken machen will
muss nicht ganz fest sein
dann gebe ich die mascarpone in meine
rührschüssel und setzte dann ganz kurz
vor mixen das dürfte auch nicht zu art
machen weil die mascarpone nämlich so
viel fett enthält und mini die zu sehr
berührt dann wird sie sehr köstlich
deswegen nur ganz kurz verhören und dann
kommt auch schon der marke quark dazu
und anschließend gebe ich auch gleich
den zucker mit rein und verrührt es
einfach nur so lange bis die massen
miteinander verrührt sind die zitrone
darf auch gleich mit dazu
erzähle ich noch die sonne unter und ihr
seht auch hier dass sie nicht ganz steif
geschlagen ist aber alles kein problem
und jetzt werde ich sie einmal ganz kurz
unterheben das mache ich jetzt mit der
maschine
das könnte aber auch ganz gut ohne
küchenmaschine machen eine creme ist
vorbereitet und steht im kühlschrank und
ich werde jetzt schnell die apple
vorbereiten putzen und klein schneiden
und dann kann das tiramisu auch schon
zusammen geschichtet werden
hier seht ihr die erdbeeren und zwar
sortiere ich die jetzt nach sehr schön
und etwas matschig und die sehr schönen
hebe ich mir auf für die deko also für
obendrauf und die etwas mutigeren nehme
ich einfach für ihnen rhein entfernt
hier einfach den strunk da bitte nicht
zu viel wegschneiden
hier habe ich jetzt die schönen
erdbeeren die festen erdbeeren geputzt
die werde ich jetzt weg legen einfach
für die deko später und diese erdbeeren
für das innere des tiramisu weil ich
jetzt einfach klein schneiden ihr könnt
sie jetzt in scheiben schneiden oder in
würfel je nachdem wer testet
meine eltern sind gewaschen geputzt
geschnitten
die creme ist vorbereitet und jetzt
gehts schon an schichten unseres teams
so skizziert in orangensaft und den
kaffee und gibt es einfach in einen
teller und wenn ihr keinen kaffee mögt
laster den einfach und nimmt stattdessen
etwas mehr orangensaft dann können auch
kinder ganz normal mit essen denn ich
denke mit kaffee sollte ob es den
kindern nicht unbedingt geben
ich nehme jetzt hier meine amara teenie
falls ihr jetzt löffelbiskuits nimmt
nehmt ihr diese und taucht sie einmal
von jeder seite ganz kurz ein und könnte
dann in tiefen schichten wie gesagt
möchte ich heute jetzt nur amara teenies
nehmen und nehmen sie jetzt deshalb und
taucht jetzt jedes mal dann aber kurz
ein und schichte so die komplette form
da nehme ich jetzt ein drittel der creme
ob ich gebe es da drauf verteilte sitzt
schön mit einer tankkarte darauf
verteile ich jetzt meine erdbeeren
angeblich noch mal eine creme schicht
rauch mit dünnere
alles kommt da noch mal eine schicht
amerika
wir sehen können fehlen da jetzt genau
ungefähr zehn bis zwölf marie teenies
das sind genau die die leider die samira
und mein mann aufgegessen haben deswegen
helfe ich mit ein paar löffel biscuit
aus aber eine packung am martini das
sind 500 gramm reichen auf jeden fall
für diese menge und da kommt jetzt noch
die letzte schicht drauf dass es noch
mal eine creme schicht
und jetzt kommt der schwierigste teil
dieses rezept und zwar müsst ihr das
tiramisu für mindestens 4 stunden im
kühlschrank ruhen lassen
einfach damit sich der ganze geschmack
entwickelt und entfaltet und das werde
ich jetzt tun und danach werde ich sie
fertig stellen meint er am ist jetzt
etwas abgekühlten noch nicht ganz aber
ich werde ich jetzt einfach mal zeigen
wie man es auch servieren kann
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier etwas
kakaopulver viele mögen könnten
kakaopulver weil sie sagen es ist ihnen
einfach so intensiv der geschmack und zu
wenig süß weil da ist keine süße mit
drin aber ich versichere euch in
kombination mit diesem tiramisu schmeckt
es richtig gut
falls ihr aber absolut nicht der kakao
fansite dann nehmt einfach charta pulver
wobei ich finde das cover zu viel zucker
enthält müsste einfach mal ausprobieren
oder ihr nehmt einfach etwas zarter
schokolade und könnte jetzt einfach
etwas trüber reiben mit einer kleinen
reihe
und jetzt habe ich hier meine erdbau die
ich mir vorhin weg gelegt habe für die
deko und die werde ich jetzt einfach
halbieren und ganz wild darauf verteilen
und jetzt suche ich mir noch ein paar
minzblättern ab und gebt ihr da einfach
auch mit drauf die minzblätter könnte
übrigens auch gerne mit ins tiramisu
reingeben also mit zu den erdball
stückchen die minze passt nämlich
richtig perfekt zu den erdbeeren und
macht das ganz einfach nochmal frische
meint er am sitz fertig und es sieht
jetzt so aus
und ihr könnt jetzt hier sehen dass hier
der kakapo schon leicht durchweicht das
heißt der kakao darf erst dann drauf
wenn ihr das auch servieren wollte ich
mein ich finde es nicht schlimm aber
eben erst kurz vorm servieren
hier könnt ihr übrigens auch sehen ich
habe jetzt hier noch eine kleine reform
gemacht einfach um euch zu zeigen hier
am rand habe ich jetzt nicht so schön
geschichtet und zwar deswegen weil ich
zu wenig erdbeeren benutzt habt wenn ihr
aber aufpasst und immer schön schaut
dass die schichten schön zu sehen sind
dann kann das ganze auch so aussehen
das heißt dann habt ihr unten die
schicht ich sieht man jetzt nicht dann
weiß rot stand wieder biscuit und hier
eben noch mal die weiße schicht unter
cacau
ihr fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich wie
man das ganze servieren soll also wir
machen das bei tieren mich so immer so
dass wir das ganze so auf den tisch
stellen und dann einen großen löffel
dazu und das darf sich jeder auslöffeln
also wir fangen da nicht an und
schneiden das tiramisu zu recht das kann
man machen wenn das nun nach dem
kühlschrank pater ist es richtig schön
fest dann kriegt man auch schön
stückchen raus aber meistens mache mir
das einfach mit einem löffel und in so
magazinen ist es ja immer alles ganz
toll abgebildet man sieht immer die
schichten richtig toll aber davon dürft
ihr euch nicht beirren lassen
denn meistens ist es so dass daten
einfach food fotografen am werk sind
das heißt die rücken des essen immer so
schön zurecht frierend es auch ein
arbeiten mit anderen massen also nicht
mit mascarpone sondern mit künstlichen
massen und krems auch mal mit schaum
masse usw
einfach um das foto richtig schön
hinzubekommen aber wie ihr es gesehen
habt kann man das auch schon hinbekommen
wenn man es einfach schön schichtet ich
schreibe ich auf jeden fall die
mengenangaben noch mal auf meinem blog
die mengen haben übrigens sehr gut
gereicht für diese eine form das war
genau ideal
ich hab dann noch mal die halbe menge
gemacht für die kleinere form dafür war
die halbe menge etwas zu viel aber wenn
ihr euch an dem rezept orientiert klappt
es mit sicherheit
ich hoffe dass euch dieses rezept
gefallen
und freue mich schon aufs nächste mal
besucht mich gerne auf meinem blog auf
www ist orten welt.de und wenn euch das
video gefallen hat gibt mir gerne eine
bewertung bis zum nächsten mal tschüss